blah blah blah blah blah hello everyone
I'm Alicia Malone this is fandango indie
movie guide and I've got some great
smaller or very original films to
suggest for you to watch this weekend
let's start with something that is
really original l by director paul
verhoeven yes robocop Total Recall
starship troopers showgirls Basic
Instinct paul verhoeven educators was
over dere she tagged a suit shim what
alright get ready hmm people hi Zeke
come yeah as you can tell from that clip
l is a French drama and it stars the
wonderful Isabelle her / she plays L
shot for Michelle a ruthless business
woman who is viciously attacked and
raped in her own home and her reaction
to that rape is not what you may expect
in fact nothing in this movie is what
you may expect and that's what I liked
about it it's twisted it's dark it's a
fascinating character study about a very
fascinating character and it takes an
actress as good as Isabel her / to pull
off a complex psychological roll like
this and do it so seamlessly good cuz i
gave a shuttle bus look good job son
awards watch on this one because L is
Frances official submission to the best
foreign language feature film category
at the Oscars next year and I wouldn't
be surprised if it gets up there so go
and see it while you can the positive my
peppers on to discover many fake
okay so my next suggestion is not
technically an indie but I'm going to
include it in this week's show because
it's one of the most surprising and
original feeling studio films that I've
seen this year I'm talking about the
sci-fi flick arrival this is per day
they arrived the object touchdown 40
minutes ago mama it's going to happen I
don't know I've been banging on about
this one since Telluride back in
September it's directed by denis
villeneuve who is fast accumulating an
impressive filmography he was the guy
that did sicario he didn't send these
prisoners enemy and right now he's
filming The Blade Runner sequel arrival
is a sci-fi film and it's about a
linguistics professor who's played by
Amy Adams and she is in charge of
communicating with aliens when they come
to earth and find out why they're here I
have something I need you to translate
for me that plot does sound like very
standard sci-fi fair but this story goes
to places that I did not expect it goes
out there it's very heady very big
concepts may divide audiences a little
bit but I have to say it works on second
viewing just as much as the first
viewing and trust me after you see this
movie you're gonna want to see it again
what does it say so how do we clarify
their intentions I go back in what is
she doing
an act of treason to trust me Awards
watchful arrival in particular Amy Adams
who I got to sit down with and chat
about this movie here's a little look
did you rate the script to second time
oh yeah finish yeah because it changed
my perspective on how I would approach
the performance you know not necessarily
the character but definitely the
performance well yeah the character is
walks out to sort of build a history for
her that would support what we're
telling the audience that she's been
through yeah and you can see more of my
interview with Amy Adams plus a chat
with her co-star Jeremy Renner all about
arrival on San tango all access YouTube
channel this week i will put the link in
the box that has the descriptions and
things below and a pic for you to watch
at home it has to be the western hell or
high water go get your money good
morning bugs open the drawers you got a
gun on you old man you damn right I
gotta go home when you're seeing from
you was sent from the back this is a neo
Western heist action thriller and it's
about these two brothers played by chris
pine and Ben Foster who want to save
their family farm so they decide to rob
some banks of course it spirals out of
control and they have sheriff after them
who's played brilliantly by jeff bridges
maybe one of these bank robbers is gonna
want a gunfight and i can dodge my
retirement in the blaze of glory
well seeing a chute won't be much glory
in hell or high water is a very simple
movie but it works so well because each
of the elements are very effective
you've got the great performances the
well-drawn characters the brilliant
dialogue and then the pacing which will
keep you on the edge of your couch you
know you talk like we're gonna get away
wish I never met nobody got away with
anything ever I'm on the hell did you
agree to do cuz you asked little brother
to sum it all up again go to the
theaters to see the very twisty French
drama l by paul verhoeven all the very
heady beautiful sci-fi film arrival by
denis villeneuve and at home you can
watch the western hell or high water by
the brilliant indie director David
McKenzie remember that name I'll see you
next week on fandango indie movie guide
by